sorry guys Leslie's eating oh are we
starting if you want oh
no I thought there's going to be like an
action Jesus
professional Whitney what the fuck I'll
give you an action we can she already
made me she already made me drive out
here too I don't know where the fuck
this is but immediately as soon as I
cross the gate my phone immediately lost
service that's the only way I can keep
people
here you can't call Ubers let me tell
you how bro this is this one you know
you a white woman
well you can give your gate code like
you can get both gate codes like I dare
you to come up here and rob me I mean I
remember one time I don't want you to
feel called out but one time oh God all
right here we go
here we go this is my Tyra moment this
is
okay and Leslie just you know is eating
chocolate pretzels this is good they're
so good I just one time I think Topher
Grace member was on the podcast and he
ate a chicken sandwich and people lost
their minds Superman oh oh oh y'all
gonna be mad I'm eating breakfast
there's like
no one time I it was your birthday oh
God and I couldn't make your birthday
party and I did I shame you no well good
I usually shame people but I got your
address and I sent you flowers I
remember that and you because that's
like how did you get my address I know
you literally text me how did you have
my address and I was like you get my
address
I was like I thought we were no you talk
to me right now we friends bro
I know I was like who the fuck is the
sauce
I know I was like so it's I'm out here I
don't have to worry about anybody even
if they have my address they're not
coming out here and if they do the
coyotes don't get them you got big dogs
I have big dogs see I'm oh I'm so glad
what I should have text that to you just
please because I'm so scared at all
that's racist
you motherfuckers
so if we gonna say some race
that's racist what you just said to me
there is some serious ancestral trauma
with dogs
[Applause]
are you dating awake right now at the
moment oh wow Hey Hey listen if this is
gonna be one of them type of interviews
bitch
I would leave your house and I'll tear
up everything on the way down I swear to
God I bet I'll break all those bosses
I'm scared the shit out that little
Mexican lady that brought me up here
because you better be treating her right
oh no she's been with me 16 years I
remember when I had nothing I had an
apartment right above the comedy store
right you know where there's that pink
dot right above uh 800 a month and what
I would do is I would hook up with guys
and when they would sell their uh they
would leave their clothes at my house
and I would sell their clothes at
Buffalo Exchange that's fucking
Savage
and also I was friends with and I've
told him this
Sean Lennon who is John Lennon's son we
were in an acting class together and
sometimes he would leave clothes at my
house when he would like just stay like
stop like wow you can get a lot of money
for Sean Lennon yeah and he would leave
the like Duran Duran like vintage
t-shirts like these one-of-a-kind
tortures and I would take them to
Buffalo Exchange and I would get like
200 for them and he would be like have
you seen my shirt that my dad left I'd
be like I haven't seen that is John
Lennon took it having my landlord has it
um I pay rent with it the landlord
um
I mean we're not I don't call it Dayton
anymore
because I've been dating I've been
and yes I am dating a white guy um
Whitney
color bitch you know what that's another
thing white people say that racist thing
you can fucking say I hate that it's
like bitch you gonna see my color I'm
not Moka hoe I'm fucking chocolate you
better and you see the fact that you're
white so you obviously see color yep
exactly it is shocking exactly anyway no
um
nah I've just realized that I don't
think uh a man's gonna fit into my life
I didn't realize that like you know how
the years and years you go oh I want a
boy I want a boyfriend I want a
boyfriend I think it's a wanting of
something that you don't have I'm trying
to fill a void and it just becomes that
Obsession of like okay I've done this
I've done this I've done this so I don't
have this I want this oh but
wow I never realized how much I love my
personal space I never realized how much
I like shit done the way that I want it
done I don't like to um compromise it's
not even compromised it's just I don't
want to do what you want to do is that
what is no compromise I want to do
because what you want to do is is
wasteful now sometimes I can go yeah
this is fun or this is I I in other
words too especially when you're dating
younger than you
it's um these dudes are still taking
chances which I'm older and now I'm just
like I've been there done that like
that's adventurous until the shit runs
out you know like
you know I I was like okay that's cool
that you want to watch TV with me yeah I
like watching TV yeah like kicking I
like smoking weed you know that's I like
smoking weed I like working that's
really all I fucking do that's like our
primary relationship man that's kind of
sad because I don't know if it's sad or
if it's just like because you wouldn't
say it was sad if it was a man if a man
was sitting here saying that you
wouldn't save a Savage you don't say a
sad because it's a woman but
I I enjoyed my fucking nights like
people be like oh you're just saying
that because you're really hurting
sidewall no I can I literally they used
to okay I'll put it like this fellas if
I was in a point in my life where I was
just saying it because I was covering up
pain because it might have been a thing
of me thinking that I can't get nobody
or nobody don't want to fuck with me or
this but I'm past that that's a phase
that you go through I'm so past that
child I could type my name into the
motherfucking internet and trust me I
will find a gaggle of motherfuckers who
want to fuck it's not it's Dick is like
not the problem of getting it's fine
insane dick
good dick is usually not connected to a
very sane person and it's almost like
God's evil joke like he goes like he's
you know first of all I feel like God is
just like straight like a hippie like
he's like he he did this and he's like
wow I didn't know this was going to turn
into this so I feel like he's up there
with this glass and he got the big block
Ice you know how they make the big black
ice and he's got scotch and he's like
swirling it
and he's like Getting Faded and he's
like wait wait wait wait wait a minute
wait a minute this is what I'm gonna do
that's what I'm gonna do that's what I'm
gonna do that's what I'm gonna do wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute
that's what I'm gonna do wait a minute
Jeremiah listen this is what I'm gonna
do that's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
put all the good dick
in the useless man
it's gonna drive crazy
Joshua
Joshua I ain't never like you anyway
Joshua that's why you ain't in the Bible
that's why you're not you don't got your
own book you know what I'm saying like I
feel like it's such a cruel joke like
do you think it's because they know it
like early on they mama and listen I'm
gonna talk to all the mamas you about to
be a mama too and if you have a
boyfriend piece of shit I'ma call you a
piece of shit right now cause you're
about to raise a piece of shit all right
well let's be a girl by the time he's
two
true that I didn't even realize that if
your kid is definitely gonna be gay your
kid is definitely going to be gay why
for sure because your kid is even gonna
be uh gay or a stunt man
it's not gonna be your normal kid have
fallen down that flight your fucking
house is a Wonderland let's just say
that okay John Mayer wouldn't even come
here oh Shalom do you all know that
there is one phase of sleep that almost
everyone fails to get enough of
nightmares you say no we all have plenty
of those because we all live in one
no the phase of sleep that we're not
getting is responsible for most of your
body's daily Rejuvenation repair
controlling hunger and weight loss
hormones boosting energy and so much
more I'm talking about deep sleep y'all
if you don't get enough you're probably
struggling with Cravings slow metabolism
premature aging or even worse conditions
in my case my delirium that I get from
not enough deep sleep makes me think I
should buy more horse statues
I've obviously struggled in the past why
don't most people get enough of this one
important phase of sleep the big reason
is a magnesium deficiency because 80
percent of our population is deficient
in magnesium that is so wild could this
be why everyone is going batshit on
Twitter this could explain so much could
this explain why everyone just goes on
and on about how tired they are while
drinking from an oversized mug that says
Thanks A Latte would magnesium make
those people go away in that case this
should be a law that we have to drink we
should start putting it in the drinking
water could the magnesium deficiency
explain why Biden and Mitch McConnell
can't say more than four words in a row
do we need to get magnesium to the White
House stat
that's my side project but magnesium
increases Gaba which encourages
relaxation on a cellular level which is
critical for Sleep magnesium also plays
a key role in regulating your body's
stress response system stress what's
that
this podcast those magnesium
deficiencies the people that have them
have higher stress levels it negatively
impacts your sleep so now before you go
out and buy some scam magnesium
supplement it's important to understand
that most products out there only have
one to two forms of magnesium when the
reality is your body needs all seven
forms of this essential sleep mineral
which is why I recommend magnesium
breakthrough I have it do you hear it
you hear it doing the Cha-Cha
magnesium breakthrough contains all
seven forms of magnesium designed to
help calm your mind and help you fall
asleep stay asleep and wake up refreshed
in my opinion this should be required by
law I started taking it I I all of a
sudden remember where my keys are I can
remember my social security number like
it's nothing and I can take naps
whenever I want which is kind of a cool
magic trick to get people to stop
talking to you I don't wake up every two
hours the way that I used to in the
middle of the night to go online and
read about all the Disney castles are
made of dicks and then ruin my circadian
rhythm for a month this is it the Deep
Sleep benefits are very very noticeable
this will change your life visit
magbreakthrough.com and enter the code
Whitney for 10 off any order this
special is only available at mag
Breakthrough by optimizers
by optimizers
this is the name of the brand I don't
know why I feel the need to really make
you guys get this because this changed
my life
magbreakthrough.com slash waiting y'all
gotta start talking to your sons this is
what I've been telling a lot of men to
talk to if you have a kid if you have a
daughter talk to your daughter about men
talk to your daughter about
relationships talk to your daughter
about how to handle men yep women it's
the same fucking thing you want to raise
the guy that women want their daughters
to to date you don't want to raise a
spoiled piece of shit asshole and women
this is gonna be fucked up for me to say
but I don't give a shit you know you the
mama you know if your kid got a big dick
well you know if that's a problem start
teaching them very early do you
understand do you understand start
getting in their ear real early like you
are special you got that special but
that doesn't mean that you're special
that I see people the way that they talk
to their kids their kids do the most
mediocre shit and they're like you're
amazing it's so annoying overly
complimental oh my God you're lying stop
giving crap participation fucking Awards
to your fucking kid cause you gonna
raise a mediocre kid but they say you
can say like you tried so hard I am so
impressed by the effort you just put so
much work into that my dad would say
that my dad would go oh wow you did so
good like I really love the way you
rebounded I really love how you hustle
but y'all lost yep that's a good next
time let's fucking do this
like when we would lose championships
and I would be like I don't want to
fucking do this I don't want to go he
would be like man you better get your
ass up Yep this ain't fucking that say I
got to go to work and deal with fucking
Bert and accountant you ain't got to do
shit but go and mope around fucking
campus where everybody's going ooh don't
worry about it that's the next year get
your ass up like let us feel the shame
this is I say this on stage a lot too
you fucking New Generation motherfuckers
it's our fault first of all with with
Whitney our parents and our parents
parents see what happened was the
trickle down happened they were like
we're gonna go through these bad hours
we're going to go through this sexual
harassment we're gonna go through this
shit but our kids won't go through that
we want to protect them from what we
want right instead of explaining to them
and fucking telling them what this is
you you Shield them from it and you
Shield them from life you Shield them
from from from consequences you've
shielded them from accountability right
and that's a fucking problem and then
they come into the workforce and then
the first person that has to deal with
them as adults some boss the fact that
you didn't prepare them for how life
really works I'm getting called into HR
because I asked them to stay an hour
late and I'm a teacher how about the
teacher has to do the and the fact that
this is another thing that's shameful
that you fucking know that the teachers
is part of your developing your child's
development and you don't fucking make
sure that they're taken care of or make
sure the right people are in place what
the fuck you just taking your kid to the
Jungle yep and just letting them go and
be like I'll be back at three o'clock I
want to go back to not needing a man to
complete you because I think there is a
huge Victory I'm 55 so girl when you get
a certain of a certain age when you 55
I'm 55 I'm 2 000 years old actually not
say I'm the 2 000 year old woman because
I've been through hell hold on
can I tell you while you're chewing that
I just re-watched your special time
machine when I tell you I recorded this
uh part incentive to people comes out in
a full knee brace over her pants and
it's it's like beige it's like an Ace
bandage that like they make I think ones
for each skin color now it's just like a
beige writing
with like a little pad on the knee in
case
over the knee I love Gladys fully over
the knee I don't fuck around and uh hold
on I've recorded it and literally sent
it to people it's it's do you know how
mature I have to be to wear a fucking
knee brace outside do you know how
mature that is you can't look I recorded
it I love it I can't I love it look Pat
in a little knee brace over her pants
you know what Chase said Chase it it
looks like a Power Ranger uniform
and oh I forgot whoever said it looked
like I was doing aerobics I'm doing
aerobics and just like I think it just
looks like you're wearing a knee brace
over your pants which is fucking wild I
tell everybody I'll be like man do you
know how fucking mature I'm you know how
responsible that is I'm a responsible
motherfucker I ain't trying to be cute
wearing it under my jeans fuck that it
don't fit under there it don't fit under
there and I don't like when my knee
turns so the knee breaks out
hey when you come up a certain age you
don't give two shits in a fuck do you
understand yeah this is so liberating
right now I mean I used to give a fuck
at Costco they used to sell it in a big
box and I used to be able to put it in
little sandwich bags and put it in my
pocket so I can pull it out when I need
to give a fuck
I don't I don't even care give a fuck no
more you know what I carry a lot of you
better get the fuck away from me I care
now that I keep from Supply I get that
from Amazon it's on it's on order yeah
the auto yeah the auto subscribe but may
I ask I find the older I get and the
less fucks I give the more younger guys
want to date oh my no this is what
pisses me the fuck because they know we
won't accuse them mean or I am or no
more like I don't give a shit they'd be
like on me like God it makes me want to
Quantum Leap back to my 20th and go
start being a fucking bitch now this
nice shit like fixing motherfuckers
breakfast and being they they think
you're a piece they think you're in
respect for you the harder you try oh
annoying because I'm a nice person
regardless like yeah if you fucking come
on I'm I'm gonna fix you something to
eat no
grab a granola bar at the back of their
head
and let me tell you something these
motherfuckers like when I tell you that
when I be so like I haven't got to the
point where I'm like you you you
wasteful I wish I was a dude so I could
show dudes how to treat a bitch like me
like you are dumb now
that's so goddamn dumb just right look
at my fucking like if I was if I was the
if I was the the man if I was the band
and they was the woman everything I'm
doing would not be offensive like yeah
yeah let's go to Ojai let's go to Ohio
just came on Dad let's go to High yeah
yeah I'm gonna pay for it because I got
more money than you you don't have to
pretend you don't get money you have to
pretend you don't pretend I don't
pretend I can't not even fucking more
I'm tired of that now you know how
fucking hard I work for my fucking money
and you know how hard I work for the
things I have and you want me to be
ashamed of that go fuck yourself what
you want me to live in North Hollywood
where I used to live at on kids in a one
bedroom apartment well 750 square feet
with motherfucking water coming through
the goddamn wall that's gonna make you
feel better faster about yourself how
about you go and fucking get yourself
together how about you go to college how
about you go to therapy you fuck nut you
fuck nut
your mama didn't tell nobody about me
because she didn't think you good enough
to have a bitch like me
oh man Whitney why you bring me here
I'll tell you what I used to when I
dated guys I dated this guy who played
an athlete who was the Sportsman I'm
like everyone told me I masculate man
you emasculate man you're too successful
so I went okay I'm gonna start dating
big strong athletes impossible to
emasculate get in the pussies always
them the biggest pussies like a
motherfucker you can hit them in the
stomach and them bitches and start
crying you could say hey your coach
don't like you and them motherfuckers
will fucking they will curl up into a
fetus position I heard you found Mr free
throw
you want better sleep better skin less
dry gross ass hair
let's do it want to stay cool through
the night and wake up with hydrated skin
hydrated hair you know you guys know
this about me you know that I'm obsessed
with silk pillowcases I've been sleeping
on silk pillowcases for years because uh
it basically stops you from getting
wrinkles because the cotton ass dry ones
you know they they soak up all that
expensive product and all those oils
that you put all that that took all the
time to put on
they just leech them out okay I don't do
cotton pillowcases I have not for years
I reapply product in the middle of the
night you guys know this about me come
back but what's the point of all that
work if you're sleeping with some nasty
ass cotton pillowcase but there has not
been a perfect silk pillowcase until now
enter Blissey sleep better with
blissey's award-winning 100
Mulberry silk pillowcase this is not a
pillowcase by the way that I'm holding
up
this is a little bag that it came in and
it's on my bed and covered in like
makeup and rude spray so I didn't want
to show it but this is the silk and I
just love touching it this is the little
baggie that it comes in unlike other
silk pillowcases these are the highest
quality silk and they're machine
washable durable and they even have a
zipper to hold your pillow in place I
love them because they're a little cold
like they're not all swampy and hot and
sweaty they're crisp they're cool they
make me feel like a Kardashian I just
feel like the Kardashians have a gnome
who just stays in their bedroom like
just and only focuses on the temperature
of the sheets I don't know these
pillowcases are the perfect temperature
right when you hit it ah blissy
pillowcases is also the perfect gift to
give when you're looking for a gift for
any occasion it's the kind of gift you
don't really know you need but it you
know people spend so much money on their
products so much money on their hair
products so much money trying to get a
good night's sleep and it's just as
simple as this they have a ton of
different prints and colors and they
make great gifts because there's an
option for literally anyone men love
them too they have over 1.5 million
raving fans at Blissey and you could be
next try it risk free for 60 nights and
get an additional 30 off that's Blissey
blissy.com Whitney use code Whitney to
get an additional 30 off sleep cooler
this summer with Blissey let me tell you
something the first date that I went on
out here is so fucking funny and I got I
got a BMW now let me tell you how much
it took me to get a BMW i I was gonna
buy two Ford edges that was the plan
they 33 000. yeah walk off the lot
thirty three thousand I was two of them
for the rest of my life
I'm saying what have you ever seen four
days it's like when you see a pair of
pants and finally fancy
together
[Music]
[Laughter]
why the fuck do I need anything else
Keenan was like if you get a Ford Edge
I'm breaking your house every night and
fucking vandalize that shit if you get a
motherfucking Uber I'm gonna be mad at
you and I was like what the fuck why
can't I have what I want he's like
people ain't gonna think you people
don't think you're not working so I was
like I don't give a fuck what people
think he's like well I give a fuck your
ass is at least gonna get the bare
minimum don't get a fucking like uh a
soccer mom car he was like get a
Mercedes or something like that I was
like I don't fucking out so dude David
Spade drives a rate a Land Rover from
like 97. trust me I trust me he we had
to fight so I ended up my business
manager wasn't going to let me buy a car
by myself so she made me get a bro I
have a broker right it's great guy so he
was like I told him my plan too and then
I told him akina said and he was like
well you know
listen I tell you what
there's a BMW dealership and I want you
to see this car
but it's right next door to the Ford if
you don't like the BMW we can go right
next door and get the Ford edges I was
like that's a goddamn plan son me and
you are going to work good because you
are compromised you are a compromising
do you understand you are a person that
sees the future you already know you're
not gonna win this your client I love
this I love that you love that you know
that you're not going to win this fight
so so we pull it I'm talking shit I'm
driving I have my friend with me I'm
talking shit the whole way I'm like yeah
I'm not gonna die and they gotta be
fucking if I'm gonna back
yeah
I'm gonna die
[Laughter]
so we pulled over into the lot and he
was like get out you know I'm not
looking at the BMW I was like they look
like Fords you know they look like the
same goddamn card they all imitating
each other but I will say this the back
of a car is very important to me ooh
that ass
oh it's got to do something I know it
sounds weird It's gotta be something I
can't explain it but it's gotta be able
to drive off and make a point I don't
know what it is it's about the back of
the fucking
fucking I didn't look like it's got
something going on like you're like what
men are with women it's so fucking
stupid but I'm at the back of the car is
very bro and because sometimes it gives
up sometimes
when it rounds off because then it
becomes very many Advantage but then
when it does that flat destruction like
yeah you're trying to get me in your
life so Ford Edge had a really good back
truck and I was like
Back That Ass Up right two of them two
of them 33 000. I knew it so we pulled
on the lot for the BMW we park and shit
and he was like come on in I want you to
see this truck he took me to the back
man uh oh when I laid my eyes on this
truck because at first he was like blue
to midnight blue it's like no I want a
black truck oh and I was just like uh it
just was like Batman that motherfucker
would spoke to me it was just BMW it was
so beautiful what's the bottle it's a
it's a dark shadow you you might not see
that because they only made 72 of these
and two of these in LA and I got one of
them that that that's a the you know you
tell that to a motherfucker like me too
it's like what it's only two of them and
I'm getting one fuck yeah what else what
else is so and let me tell you what's so
cool about it is that my my I have you
know my business man because I don't
really spend money so my business
managers was like yo you gotta spend
some money man like there's a lot you
got to spend some money on something
substantial I was like do you feel like
you had a like uh when I first started
making
so how much does that mean I got left
and there's like ma'am don't you got
business I asked you bitch you know you
there with the money but you know it
didn't really work like that but I buy
stuff and return it right away I don't
do that but I do ask my business manager
every time I see it and my financially
okay and she'd just be like I I mean
this is not the place I would tell you
that and it's like we have a whole
meeting and no that seems like you're
great like but but we had to spend some
money so she was like I want you to buy
with cash so I was like what do you mean
like cash like go to the bank again
she's like no idiot choose your card I
was like that's not cash that's like she
was like I'm not gonna stay on the phone
with you this isn't a Katt Williams Show
it's not a bag of cash yeah you know
that's what I'm thinking I'm like I
gotta go to the bank she's like they're
not gonna she's like just tell the
broker you're buying to cash I was like
okay whatever because in my head I'm
like do I need to go to the bank yeah I
mean suitcase you know come in with you
know with a combinations
so I looked at the broker and I was like
she keeps saying buy it to cash she was
like okay and I was like well what that
mean he was like you paying cash for the
car and I was like okay
listen
y'all the technical people but all I
know is that when they said I was gonna
buy cash everybody in that dealership
was like
yep
what was so funny was all the black
people was like no
yeah man I remember this so but yeah
doing stuff like that when you do stuff
like that you become like um you really
do work hard and when somebody tell you
that they need to do you need to soften
yourself or you're Intense or there's a
lot of pressure you go go fuck yourself
with a very sharp and deep knife and
take a long walk on a short pier let me
ask you so you're say you're going on a
date with a guy you let him drive your
car
you know I let him drive it today he
drove his home because I I wanted him to
shut up so I wanted to give him
something to do so you could drive
because then you have to concentrate on
the road and you ain't got to talk to me
so it's more that instead of I'm gonna
be the lady and let you drive Who you
calling the late I've never I'm never a
lady ever
one time I'm a lady is like right before
sex I'll write them up a little bit I
film up what does that look like just it
don't look like nothing but
foreign
[Music]
like last night last night I dressed up
I dressed up I put on a dress I was like
At first I was just gonna I was actually
gonna wear this to the restaurant and I
was like oh no he's never seen me dress
up so I went to the bathroom he was like
yo we got like a 45 minutes like a
dinner date yeah and you didn't do spots
so he was like you know it was our last
night and he was like I was like you
know something last night let me go in
this bathroom I went in the bathroom and
you know got all pretty and glossed it
up and put my hair and put my lashes and
you know yeah and put the lips I even
put a shaper on I was like let me shape
this shit that's under here you know
shape it into something nice and then
put you know the sweat suit on put the
sweatshirt the sweat suit and um you
know that's I starting to realize being
a dominant that's what they like they
like even though they tell you that they
love you in your natural state the slut
suit has to come out once in a while and
when I came out there he was like oh
shit yeah you're dating Leslie Jones and
she's bigger than life you better
fucking recognize like fucking recognize
you know what I'm saying so it is we did
women did recently start dressing like
Adam Sandler just all the time because
I'm like do I have to wear the shorts do
I have to wear my eyes to dinner because
these are people who are now realizing
that we're not in that plan of Prince
Charming to fucking rescue us yeah I
don't I'm not saying that I don't want a
man in my life and I always tell me in
this I don't need to be rescued
motherfucker I rescued myself how about
you Joel and join in with the ride like
jump in the ride like this is a nice
ride and then my number one complaint
from all my guy friends is like she's a
mess she doesn't make any money I'm
stuck with her I'm like we're
self-sufficient we have our shit
together you know who who loves like us
men that have been through a bad divorce
and then them motherfuckers are so
fucking uh uh cynical you have to be
like shut the fuck up I'm not that bitch
yeah yeah I'm not that bitch like and
and you know what I guess it would be
the same too with divorced women who
probably like put on this shit on on the
end too I understand that there's a
balance but it's like where the fuck do
I fit in because I am a woman who has
confidence in herself who has confidence
in her in a career who who enjoys I I'm
sexual being I understand I love my body
and I love to have sex and I know how to
have sex and I know what it is that I
want I who wants bad sex I don't want to
just who the fuck you'd be surprised
like you know what this is a rule that
you literally need to live by and I say
this all the time and they probably have
me all over the place saying it to
Laverne Cox but desperate that's
desperation is a big thing and it's not
just with career it's with your life
like I was thinking today I'm not no
desperate bitch ain't nobody desperate
and when you pick me and maybe I might
have picked this person out of
desperation because I wanted a boyfriend
yeah or I thought that's what okay
that's what I gotta fulfill now
like I'm making all this money and who
am I gonna kick it with and all that and
I was kicking it and most of the time I
was like oh when when did this person
gonna go home or and I was like oh no
they're there for a minute like what if
we move in together oh my god oh am I
gonna have to give him a closet oh okay
wait a minute oh are you gonna move okay
can you I like and nobody got yourself
too long and most guys main complaint is
women move too fast she wants me to be
in her closet she wants me to have a key
I'm like I'm the perfect bitch for you
I'm the one that is not gonna like make
you move in too fast I've got my own
life I'm gone every night I'm gone every
weekend this is perfect and then it gets
and then it's like oh well now you're
not here like this is this is what I got
or they're like I'm intimidated by you
you're too busy for me this is the first
time I'm not the main uh thing in the
what what does that even mean why would
you want to be I think the most
successful relationships the
relationship is I mean forget having
kids and stuff you come in second so
that I'm not putting all this pressure
on you I'm not
told me that I feel like this is an
arranged marriage and I'm the girl
what
what is it I I didn't even understand I
know what that means I don't that's why
I told myself you can't even explain to
me because you were you giving him lots
of like orders
I don't fuck no we were together like we
was just like I don't I mean you're in
my house if we're doing stuff and we're
going places and I was telling them like
I know yo
you guys know that 35 of all fatal
accidents occur between 6 p.m and
midnight
that makes sense doesn't it but it's
also kind of wild 35 you know people
ages 25 to 34 have the highest amount of
drivers involved in car crashes if
you're ever injured you can check out
Morgan and Morgan Morgan and Morgan is
America's largest injury Law Firm they
have over 100 offices Nationwide 800
lawyers or any of them single
with over 15 billion dollars recovered
for over 300 000 clients Morgan and
Morgan has a proven track record of
fighting to get you full and fair
compensation Morgan and Morgan has been
fighting for the people for over 35
years submitting an injury claim with
Morgan and Morgan is so easy look I'm
pregnant being pregnant is hard
it's hard I'll tell ya trust me I want
to file a claim against the the man that
injured me with this baby but submitting
an injury claim with Morgan and Morgan
is easy life is hard submitting a claim
after someone hits you should not be
weed is now legal and everyone just
thinks we're in a simulation and that
we're playing bumper cars all of a
sudden we need someone to protect us
from the drivers that are shooting tick
tocks lives while the rest of us are
trying to go to the donut store okay a
lot of Maniacs out there
if you're ever injured you can check out
Morgan and Morgan their fee is free
unless they win for more information go
to forthepeople.com Whitney or dial
pound law
pound 529 from your cell phone that's
for for the people.com Whitney or pound
law pound 529 from your cell phone this
is a paid advertisement I think
sometimes I've heard the weirdest shit
when guys are getting spooked and I'm
like I don't even know if you believe
what you're saying like I think I told I
told them I said you're like men lie so
much that they lie to themselves and
don't even realize they're lies they're
lying and listen this because I don't
want this to be the like a man hate
thing because it's not a man-hating this
is more of a like I really wish men
would just be fucking self-aware of your
mental fucking State like women are
doing the work like we do the work
because that bitches though you can't
get a lot of shit past that like we're
not gonna buy into your fucking shit and
then plus I'm older too been there done
that it's like again mental what I find
a lot and oh my God you and your fathers
Jesus just solve it already dude you got
you got any goddamn cartoons and fucking
villain movies do I have to watch what
you pieces of shit before you just go
talk to your daddy
dude you and your dads need to go into
the woods you're gonna go out the woods
and fight each other
what the fuck I don't get what the fuck
is happening just Jesus wept on the
computer I had to hold a man in Mexico
who was crying watching fences girl I
have held multiple men shaking multiples
multiple men and and then what they
tried to do is after they cried like
they fucking babies they try to fuck you
because then they want to feel they need
to choke you and yeah fuck you now you
just cry like little Willy Wonka bitch
get the fuck off of me get out like it
is it's very it's it's so it's like very
annoying but I'll be telling man all the
time it's not bad to get fucking therapy
women have been doing the work for years
because we've had to you motherfuckers
complain so much about us and about our
mentor and about the problems we have
with our father or our mother or
whatever we've went through and we went
and did the fucking work and you stood
back and not did the work with us
because we just expressed our emotions
more so we're like you're crazy you're
psycho you got to go to therapy you want
to do the same thing but then you want
to Gaslight us about the shit instead of
just fucking going and getting the
fucking help and admitting that you
fucking need some goddamn mental health
instead of going to get some mental help
you guys are going to CrossFit and
sitting in ice bath no no don't get that
shit or fucking just walking out the
Middle Street and letting the mack truck
hit you you dumb fuck I'm just so tired
and then any anyone any man who needs to
say to me oh yeah well I've been to
therapy and I've been all the way
through it you're a dick fuck and you
really need to go the fuck back to your
doctor fucking get some goddamn therapy
it's actually the most gangster man
thing you can do it's one of the biggest
Investments while you're fucking at the
gym investing into a trainer or these
fucking pills or this fucking I'm being
a man shit invest into some shit that's
actually gonna work for you because in
the long run when you do find a woman
and mentally scar her and then have kids
with her and mentally scar them and then
mentally scar yourself because you're
gonna lose all of it because only thing
you had to do was take care of yourself
it's just
too obvious I can't I I I I I I can't
even tell you the idea that like therapy
is weak or it's bitch or something like
that talking about your feelings with
somebody or just saying like yeah it is
the most the bravest shit you can do the
bravest shit and you saving not only
everybody's are you saving your own life
like so much shit people you people
don't understand being human is hard men
are walking into schools with guns being
murdering motherfuckers and I'm telling
you right now the the only release that
y'all giving yourself is to have sex
with a woman or or just like exercise no
I honestly think like and most men don't
have friends too you know a lot of men
don't have friends a lot of men don't
have friends I think it's very hard
that's why and if they do have friends
it has to be in some group it has to be
at a sports game really weird it's very
weird they and they're scared to talk to
each other it's just like it's just it's
like y'all gonna Y'all Gonna thin out
you're gonna die the fuck out because
like whether you like it or not God
we'll figure out how to have kids
without you motherfuckers nope
like fuck off motherfucker like I am I
just so tired I think there's also with
so watching so much porn guys guys are
watching all this morning yeah it's in
and and I'm sure women watching porn is
bad too in a lot of ways listen but I
think when I see guys on dating apps I
think the more fake access they think
they have to women it's like no like no
Pat you're passing on a bunch of women
that might even be out of your league
rejecting women and your bars getting
higher and higher with this imaginary
production it's so it's so crazy because
men don't understand that porn is
pretend and you don't have a porn dick
your dick is is a regular dick those are
professional dicks those dicks have
managers they have a glen they have a
Glam team they have they have like you
know an age health insurance you know
they have insurance and shit they get
days off you know those are professional
dicks they have learned how to actually
do the fucking that you're watching you
average mediocre dick motherfucker get
in your motherfucking Lane and how about
listen to a bitch when she telling you
how to fuck her cause let me tell you
something and I'm I'm looking am I
looking right into the camera I'm
looking right into the camera I want
every man to hear this and I need you to
hear this all from my motherfucking the
bottom of my goddamn pussy I need you to
hear this every woman Every Woman every
woman as much as you think you can fuck
the shit out of a woman no one can fuck
a woman better than she can fuck herself
you better fucking back the fuck up from
that trophy that you hold them upon
yourself you understand because nobody
gonna fuck up better than she is
to die
you're talking about this like the the
audacity with which a man will slide
into my like a dating app DM
so mad at me already mad at me like
confrontational anger gaslighting coming
in so first first you wanna cause I
always do this selfie can I get a selfie
because I need to see if you're not a
bot and you know and do answer this
question I always make them answer a
question because I'll be like I don't
want to see oh so now you're demanding
unmatched I don't even argue with
motherfuckers I I met all the the
wonderful thing about some of these apps
I match I'm not gonna argue with you
crazy person I'm mad why are we in a
fight right away I'm like from
the dude that I said that had your name
oh that was so weird he was like he was
like so because I was like how tall are
you you know I mean because he initiated
and then you wrote back let me see a
picture how tall are you like
to say the picture I just asked because
I knew what he looked at the picture let
me knock out a couple I was just like
just calling you I was like I'm six feet
tall so but how tall are you he was like
I'm 5 10. are you okay with clinically
asking me now how like a match you think
you because it was like he's like I saw
you at uh you remember when Tammy used
to have the shows on the Rooftop at the
Magic Castle one night I said I met you
this is what I said to him I said he
said I met you there one night and uh
you know we had a really good
conversation and I was like oh wow why
didn't we match then why didn't you try
to come on to me oh oh little pretty
that's not how it works so I started
laughing because I was like oh maybe he
trying to be funny because I thought
that was you know kind of funny I was
like oh okay well do you live in L.A he
was like yeah I live in L.A and then I
said
how tall are you because I'm you know
you know how to he was like well you
know uh 510 are you finished clinically
asking me questions oh I match
and I hope oh I this is what I'll be
praying for this is what I'll be praying
for it because God never does it for me
he never lets me run into Karen's he
never he never lets me he never lets me
run into a racist man you gotta go to
Trader Joe's he never oh dumb bitches
see Karen's all Karen's love me I'm I'm
I'm I'm I'm a goddamn Unicorn it's crazy
they they those the Karen's always
coming to me go I that you know that
they are because they go I'm a fan they
start off the conversation with I
supported you
and I'm a fan I'm I'm actually a big fan
and you know what I can do I go do you
have me tattooed across your ass cause I
met a girl who got me my face tattooed
across her ass that's my number one fan
so
she had to get off the pocket just your
face your whole face just my whole face
bitch with the Mohawk and everything and
I'm I think my mouth is in the crack so
every time she she her she does
something I think I smile on her ass
it's fucking great where is she from I
have no idea and I do not want to know
is that why you were so paranoid about
me having your address
that bitch show up and be like
if somebody uh has me tattooed on him
and I was like that's a fan that's cute
but um um but coming in with anger man
there's there's insecurity and there's
anger and I think there's this once we
talking about I was about to say he was
um in your DM saying why are you
clinically uh diagnosing how tall I am
and this is what I pray for because this
is what I was starting I was like God
doesn't let me have this though because
he knows I'm crazy I pray I pray that
I'm at a common Club because he said we
met at a comedy club I
I pray that he has the audacity to walk
up to me and go we were talking on Raya
and you unmatch me oh please
[Laughter]
let me tell you I show my ass in
Montreal
you'll be proud of me but
you know white men white men I'm pretty
sure they're gonna be somewhere causing
problems but did you ever do Uptown
Comedy Club in Atlanta probably not your
wife no but it used to be punchline
Atlanta was the club that I feel like I
used to always do before they used to be
Uptown Comedy because it's what all the
black comments wins is that earthquake
explosive yeah yes yes so this guy that
used to book at Gary piece of shit and
he can you know they always have the
audacity to come up to you after you
know they just been a piece of shit
promoter you know you know what you go
through trying to get that money they
put you in shitty hotels that treat you
like that
and then they they you get there they
got six comments going up before it's
just like fucking total disrespect so he
walks up to me at the Montreal thing and
I knew I recognized them but I didn't
recognize him right away and he goes he
goes yeah Leslie don't you remember me
I'm Gary and I was like Gary Gary he was
like yeah I booked the Uptown Atlanta
and Whitney I am in that place I stop
and and I'm I'm I love that I'm so
dramatic now I love that I take my time
now because this is shit that I would
get home and go oh I wish you would have
said this yeah I say now what I wish I
say it now so I stopped I did a whole
dramatic thing and I go oh my God like I
was about to I was like oh my God oh my
God my mind always detect asshole oh
and I looked right at him and I'm
telling you everybody I was standing
with Lenny and everybody was like they
were smiling and they went
someone needs to say it and he was like
Leslie what are you talking about I I I
I thought I treated you would no you
didn't you treated me like shit you
treated every comic like shit like fuck
you and now you're trying to kiss my ass
say what I said I got to be faking I'm
not fucking fake and I never fake was
then and I'm not fake now you
disrespected me that and now you're
disrespecting me now that's what I said
and do you know what I ended the
conversation with but it's good to see
you still alive
did you know 80 of people have
subscriptions they've forgotten about
that's so wild this is how these con
artists make money think of how many
free trials you've subscribed to that
you probably never canceled I had such a
big wake-up call I was still paying for
so many apps I didn't even know about at
first I thought Rock of money it would
just be you know they would show you all
of like the gym memberships that you
never really canceled or all the things
automatically being charged to your
credit card I didn't even know about all
the apps that were still charging me
first of all like three dating apps Raya
which I have been off for years okay
I make fun of it all the time but who
has the last laugh them because I'm
still paying for it okay I was paying 70
a month I had totally forgotten about
this for I'm not gonna say the name of
the app but uh because I'm about to make
fun of it a hiking app that gives you
trails to hike on
did you hear that Pat yeah yeah I mean
surprised you didn't have more time to
use it
well I had gotten it during the pandemic
to be like oh yeah every time I go to a
city I'm gonna like go on a hike and
then and I even looked at it I was like
70 a month is this just where serial
killers use this app to figure out where
to bury people like and it was like oh
find out what other people thought of
this hike I'm like that's just the
internet like why I realized I spent I
was this is embarrassing Seventeen
hundred dollars a year on weird
subscriptions I must have signed up for
during the pandemic when I was in a deep
psychosis because the blue hair dye was
leaching into my brain thanks rocket
money with rocket money you can easily
cancel the subscriptions you don't want
with the Press of one button no more
long hold times annoying emails with
customer service rocket money does all
of the work for you rocket money can
even negotiate lower bills for you by up
to 20 percent uh all you have to do is
take a picture of your bill rocket money
will take care of the rest rocket money
also lets you monitor all your expenses
in one place recommends custom budgets
based on your past spending they'll even
send you notifications when you've
reached your spending limits that's a
game changer with over three million
users and Counting rocket money
customers have saved an average of seven
hundred and twenty dollars a year that's
720 things at the dollar store
stop wasting money on things you don't
use cancel your unwanted subscriptions
and manage your money the easy way by
going to rocketmoney.com Whitney that's
rocketmoney.com Whitney rocketmoney.com
y'all know about quipp
so I'm currently with Childs and
something nobody tells you about when
you get pregnant is that your gums just
start bleeding
you just start hemorrhaging from the
mouth
it's pretty cool I don't know if it's
Nature's Way of deterring other men from
trying to sleep with you
I'm not sure the biological basis of
this but the oral hygiene is key I went
to the dentist I'm now going to go twice
a year
um which I think is what it's supposed
to be but whatever she was like you need
to start coming more because you're
pregnant and you need to get a better
toothbrush like I had been using quip on
and off but sometimes I would travel and
I wouldn't have it with me but now I
never leave the house without my quip
okay good health starts with good habits
quit makes it Easy by delivering all of
the Oral Care Essentials that you need
to care for your mouth now this most
electric toothbrush does annoy me most
of them like tickle and feel
uncomfortable and you have to like press
it down really hard and it's a hassle to
replace them you're not sure how long
you're supposed to be doing it for it's
just like a big mess quip is a game
changer because they have timed Sonic
vibrations with 30 second pulses to
guide okay a dentist recommended two
minute clean lightweight Sleek design
it's very cute it's very attractive no
wires or bulky Chargers you know the
ones you have to balance it on the thing
and then there's like dry toothpaste on
it so it doesn't balance on the thing so
you don't know that it's charging it's
just a hot mess quip solved all of that
multi-use travel cover that doubles as a
mirror so you can mount it so it's like
you can put it right on the shower
reusable handles and a range of sleek
metal Hues I have the rose gold one it's
very sexy as well as bright plastic
colors
uh to make a pop on your bathroom
counter if you're if you're that guy
skip the batteries snap into healthy
habits with the new rechargeable
electric toothbrush all the features of
the original quip plus one magnetic
charge Powers up to three months of
brushing
it's longer than most of my
relationships if you go to getquip.com
Whitney right now you'll get 20 off any
electric toothbrush mint and gum
dispenser or water flosser that's 20 off
any electric toothbrush mint and gum
dispenser or water flosser at
getquip.com
Whitney sorry I'm burping that's another
pregnancy thing but it's spelled get
g-e-t-quip.com
Whitney quip the good habits company has
there been anything you felt like I mean
I kind of feel like this Narrative of
like we can't say anything is Comics I
think it's the opposite I think they
want us to go I think I think they do
want us to go harder but I think that
they're always okay I give it up to
anyone who can do that hardcore shit and
just do it and be brave enough to do it
but I always say me I do like to to to
uh uh not trigger warning but I do
soften the blow sometimes if I know I'm
gonna go hard I always say listen y'all
might not like what I'm about to say I
might start like that or listen I'm
about to say some shit that's crazy I
always do that because I always want
people to know this this is my opinion
this is not the opinion of everybody in
this room this is what I'm thinking this
is what I'm feeding you I am not the all
and be all and plus I'm a fucking comic
and my job is to make you laugh and that
is something that sometimes Comics
forget and sometimes the audience that's
sit in a comic audience forget is that
this is comedy our job is to make you
laugh instead of cry is to make all this
fucking shit that's going in the world
to make some comedy out of it so we
don't start killing ourselves in the
middle of the fucking Street well you
are also a master of your craft like I
mean that's a dorky thing to say I know
but I mean watching your special like
this is masterful you're like this is
not something anyone that has been doing
this less than 25 years right could ever
the prince thing you I mean you don't
say a word for like eight minutes oh my
God and aren't those the best jokes and
you're just and it's just you're surfing
and it's a true story though you're
surfing you're surfing and can I get my
ponytail back it's just like that's like
you can't do that in the first 15 years
of being a comic and when people are
like I don't like that this comic joked
about this thing and there's some comics
where I'm like you haven't earned the
right to talk about it you can do it
you're just probably not gonna get away
with it because you don't have the skill
set it also I don't even tell them that
I just go I remember when I was coming
up I was writing jokes that I knew I
wouldn't be able to do until I was
actually really skilled slave joke that
I that started off I wrote that joke in
1992 I didn't start doing that joke
until 2014. like you knew I'm not gonna
be able to handle this like and not make
it to what it was going to be because
it's one of those tricky subjects that
you gotta make that shit instantly
mindfully funny and like so funny that
they're like
for lack of a better word get away with
something or handle a subject matter in
a way that makes sense there's certain
jokes I have where I'm like this is
gonna be perfect when I'm 50. right like
that's when I should talk about this
more jokes oh my God the joke that I do
in Time Machine the gigolo when I say
every time I see myself do it I get so
depressed because that joke should have
had five years that joke should have had
a five year run so it could be beautiful
that joke was when when I first started
doing it me and Lenny was like oh this
is not going on a special this needs to
develop but it started getting so good
and then it was like it's got to go and
especially I was like Lenny I'm not
finished with that joke yet that joke is
every time I see it I go all the Sprouts
that that's a that's something we left
on that's money we left on the table
right there because it's it's some jokes
that I write that are jokes that I've
had in my heart for a while like like
the stuff that I'm doing now this is
like the set that I'm developing now
time machine like Problem Child was 20
years of material time machine was to
show y'all I am skilled and now I am a
professional comedian I am skilled I do
this for a living this next special is a
mixture of both it's like damn she funny
as fuck and she been doing this for a
while so these are these are jokes that
are but also I mean time machine there's
this moment where this crowd work moment
we're talking about 20 year olds and
there's this girl wearing a sweater and
it's just you're like the way she
handles it you're like there's just no
comic that hasn't been doing this 20
years where that moment could ever
happen God it's because you do it a
thousand times you find a thousand
sweaters to do that too I mean people
think that of course and that's how good
you make it look you make it look like
it's the first time you did that joke
but it's just to what it's I can't it's
like watching an ice skater knowing
they're gonna stick to like because
that's to me the best like watching it
going oh God I got building the tension
building the tension building the
tension then oh my God I'm safe in this
person's hands like you know I never
have to be worried about this person I
never have to worry this person's gonna
fall and then two also like now I can
really enjoy this person's performance
because I am she's not gonna let me down
you know what I'm saying that that's
where I trust people I like to give
people to that point where they're like
okay anything this bitch says I'm gonna
laugh at because God damn it it's so
fucking great and and when you're up
there creating it too that's what it
feels like I'd be like oh I can't wait
to say this oh I can't wait to say this
who say this who say this it's fun can I
ask about I've always seen you as so
Fearless like would you say that you
know
um you know getting famous the negative
side of Fame which no one no one
prepares you for here's a bunch of money
now have a bunch of people are gonna say
they want to kill you or a bunch of
people that say that they love you
and that they love you and that you're
there there you're you're you're you're
you're the reason that they're living or
or oh my God I would not have done this
without you or if I hadn't seen you like
it's really fucking like I'm in Ralph's
I just want some fucking tomatoes I
don't want to hear about your aunt
that fucking watch me on SNL
I don't fucking even remember that
sketch but you have to like that's part
of the job
but it's it's hard it's a lot of
emotional bandwidth people don't
understand too I'm very empathetic so
um whenever people touch me and want to
hug me or it's just you taking my energy
and it feels like it it oh my God in the
beginning the hardest part was the
pictures the hardest part was getting
photos taken because every time because
no one knows how to use their own
fucking phone no and then every time
they would take a picture I literally
would feel in my eyes it felt like life
was leaving my body I just hated the
pictures oh Ghostbusters was the hardest
time ever it was press like I remember
just I remember we was in Miami and I
ran into Will Smith and Will Smith was
like you don't get paid for the movie
you get paid to do press and it was
fucking hard it was hard so yeah because
it's also where entertainers like when
I'm not entertaining I don't know what
I'm supposed to be doing with myself am
I po am I trying to look sexy what do
you want from me and into a a lot of
people they I don't know what they want
from me sometimes because they'll stand
there and they'll go oh my God you this
this and this and then you go oh thank
you so much I really appreciate it and
then they keep talking and you go thank
you so much I really appreciate what do
you want me to say I want for this to
end and then if you end it you're a
bitch if you go thank you and walk off
like I'm talking to you I've supported
you I'm a fan well bitch You Don't Own
Me Tell me about this book what's in it
is there is there they have the fucking
Jones baby Leslie Jones
because there's a lot of stuff that I
feel like I don't want it's gonna be a
lot of stuff in there and I'm scared
because I don't know how people are
going to receive it to me that's the
best feeling you should have before you
know you wrote A Brave book if you're
scared I'm scared when I wrote mine I
was like I'm gonna get sued my family
members are gonna disown me All My Exes
Are Gonna assume man too I'm like is it
accurate cause like I smoke weed so it's
and and then my thing is it's like the
way I see it might not be the way to
somebody y'all saw it so I'm I'm nervous
about people coming out and going bitch
that's not how that happened and and the
only answer I can go is that's how I
remember it and it's tricky because like
as a comic you're like what's a story
for the book and what is an on stage
story you know so how did you decide
what was going to go in here versus what
you're going to talk about oh it was it
was I put everything in there first and
then just took shit out that's how you
do it we just I said everything and then
took everything out
oh this really is a fake book in here it
is oh this is like this is I was like
reactive food if there's a chapter about
no I have that in mind oh because I want
to be a nutritionist no this is a
metabolism plan discover the foods and
exercises
that's so fucking funny the day I
started talking about metabolism y'all
go and check something God damn it but
yeah it's um it's gonna be it's a good
one in the audio have you read your
audiobook yet oh man audio I didn't read
one word in that book the audio is all
free stories and I just went from
chapter to chapter telling what really
happened
and you kind of just like Rift on it
instead every the first when we did the
first chapter I stopped and I I said I
said to the director I was like okay
we're gonna have to redo that because I
didn't read nothing in that chapter he
was like we were not that was fucking
exactly what we wanted like I started
locking up my jaw started locking up
when I was reading my audiobooks I was
trying so hard to get it right into read
and then I was like what am I doing let
me just like go nope I was just telling
them stories I would I would start to I
would start reading and then I would I
would read some of it and then just go
right into the story you talk about like
SNL like all this stuff it's so good
it's really I'm gonna
what are some like big lessons you took
from SNL you
you always think that people that leave
s m
are
hated the place or whatever it's like
any job that you went to and really
worked the hard and had a hard time is
ups and downs is people that you don't
like people you do like shit happens
there's a lot of pressure cooker and
it's two it's two jobs mental and
physical you know it's it's a 100 hours
a week it's a hard job but I will tell
you I learned how to write I learned how
to cast I learned how to direct I learn
how to produce you that that is
definitely uh on Comedy college and like
the wisdom like I mean I was talking to
John Friedman once and she said like
Lauren Michaels always says like never
tell a crazy person they're crazy that's
such a good nuggets so too he used to
always say y'all think y'all need more
time than a week to make a show you
don't you have more time you're gonna
fuck it up and overall neurotic comments
were like I need two years to write two
jokes and the one thing I learned to
there how to cut
how to cut oh my goodness when I first
got there oh I used to be so sensitive
when they would cut this or cut that
that's just pressure and I used to be
like and then when when they would cut
it and we would do it it would be so
clean I would be like damn so I started
loving the cut I love the cut now
writing is cutting I think the best time
machine matter of fact I wanted it to be
I wanted it to be 58 minutes I think it
ended up being like a hour four but I
wanted it to be 58 minutes and it was
like 20 minutes over and I was in New
York but I put me and Lenny on a plane
we flew out
and we cut that shit he was like you
want to cut I was like yes cut that look
take this out that's too much air Bam by
the time we finish Jesse Collins I
remember Jessica Collins going fuck man
yeah man yeah we did that shit in three
hours no fat zero fat I love I love it I
love it especially even more so people
are watching things they're doing 10
things at once there is and you don't
understand like they watching it and
they thinking oh that's supposed to be
in there all that air take that all that
wow two minutes before I start talking
again take that shit out and also what
Comics do when they're let's do this
whole big Applause break people are
watching there's the show that you shoot
and then there's the show that you put
out to the world the people that weren't
there they don't want they don't need
this pan shot this is why I tell Comics
too and these new comics
respect comedy as a craft respect the
craft for comedy just like you respect
singing acting art anything that's an
entity please respect it because it's
going to be here after you die so you're
nothing special but you're just a vessel
stop trying to reinvent the wheel
whenever a singer learns a song whenever
a singer changes a song up they know the
original song first don't come in here
and try to fucking outwit the original
like comedy been here longer than you
have it will let you be creative if you
give it respect if it and but that's
anything singing anything if you respect
it the craft will let you have your fun
and your creative things will be fucking
snapping but if you think you're better
than the entity then you're gonna lose
every time seeing I'm not obviously not
going to name names and I won't mention
like alt comedy was the thing which was
like we're above we're above comedy what
about the one who did the one without an
audience you did a stand-up show with no
people in the audience that's not a
stand-up show no that's a fucking mirror
time that's a goddamn mind work except
Norm McDonald's that he did during the
pandemic but Norm Macdonald
that's an audience do you get what I'm
saying yeah well people who think that
they just can do shit I'd be wanting to
drop kick motherfuckers man like you
trying to fucking bake a cake without
flour
and it's like that's the thing that it's
like when people are mad at Comics or
whatever it's like we get up we leave
the house every night at nine PM okay we
put you before so we don't even know
who's gonna be in the audience you can
be a bunch of murderers you can have
voted for someone that doesn't want me
to be able to you know vote I have no
idea you can hate women you could be a
bunch of Saudis I am going to show up
and make your ass laugh all I care about
is making you laugh all I give a shit
for like 25 I'll make like 25 maybe you
make 25 shit
and like I am I am like giving
everything just to make you guys laugh
for 15. and and then now they got this
thing where they're throwing shit at the
people on stage listen let me explain
something to y'all y'all think that I'm
from SNL or NBC I am
I am from fucking Compton I will jump
the fuck out in that audience and I will
stomp a mud hole in your motherfucking
ass like like everything
me and Chris talk about that Will Smith
shit I said man let me tell you
something first of all with Will Smith's
huge ass I would have just ran around
the stage I'd have been like well
it wouldn't have been able to catch me
yo what's wrong with you nigga calm down
I would have been like come on
[Music]
I'm saying it's just like oh my God like
but I've been in shows where I've seen
people walk on stage and get their ass
whooping comic man I've seen
motherfuckers get knocked out with mic
stands I said let me tell y'all
something I am a crazy ass bitch I'm not
gonna stop fighting you until four
people are on me I didn't fought so many
people in fucking The Comedy Store I
came out throwing water at this uh white
dude that said something he fucking
wanted to fight me I said motherfucker
I'll be off in two minutes
literally pulled me into the back bro
Brody was like Leslie no no
I threw the water at him and I hit Sarah
Tiana
[Music]
I am fucking crazy please don't be a
dumb motherfucker throw something at me
on face cause I'ma whoop your ass
I'm going to jail do you not understand
that my business manager have Leslie's
gonna whoop somebody ass fun and Joe
she's got cash that she won't spend she
literally Leslie's gonna whoop
somebody's ass fund there's something I
that Will Smith thing I do think it kind
of emboldened it started some weird
butterfly effect dude like the Chappelle
thing happened that girl had the beer
can thrown at her shit cardi B had to
throw Mike at a bitch well that ends and
Lady uh uh Pink someone threw her Mom's
ashes at pink what someone threw uh Bebe
rexha someone threw her cell phone hit
her in the face oh my God I'm telling
you right now yo yo let me tell you uh
after this after the show and I don't
even do it I used to go and Shake
people's hand
this girl tried to pull me off the stage
uh y'all I want you to come down come
down here and this bitch yanked on me
and when I say Whitney I yanked on this
bitch so hard she almost came on the
stage I said bitch go
yo
and her all her friends I was like and I
looked and I said what the fuck is wrong
with you the fuck is wrong with you they
don't expect that shit because then now
they're like
we didn't made less insurance man yeah
bitch it's weird cause they're people
are like I could never do what you do
you're a comic and then after you
perform for them all of a sudden they've
lost respect for you and you're just
property and like it doesn't even make
sense and groups of girls that have
drank a lot like they'll play like
though oh man too man too man I've had
men grab my titty I didn't have
motherfuckers like uh oh my God you just
no and then two it's almost like y'all
become temporarily insane yeah when
you're around a star I've had men tell
me hey my wife said that I can go home
with you hey hey our wife come up to me
and go hey my husband likes you can he
go home with you I'd have had gay women
propose to me I didn't have gay women
break down into tears about how they
want to marry me I didn't have men break
down into tears about how they want to
marry me is fucking insane can I ask you
though I love it being around a famous
person makes you a temporarily insane
have you ever acted insane around a
famous person I know that's how I know
they're temporarily insane
Tom Hanks I lost every bit of my shit
when I first met Tom Hanks I could not
stop talking about all the movies that
he was doing I got him in a fucking
corner he was out in the benches in the
corner I was like Tom and people will
and Tom literally did like this he went
[Music]
oh my God I'm so sorry I'm doing that to
you and then I remember uh Jim Carrey
was there Jim Carrey hadn't had the
beard and Jim looked so incredibly sexy
that day and I put my hand in his beer
and I was like Jim this is fucking sexy
this is really fucking sexy this is
doing it for me and then Tom was like
that's the Leslie I want to kick it with
like
I think I don't
know I got an Oscar for some of those
shits like wait I have there's a couple
really funny stories about uh Tom Cruise
at SNL I think this was before you were
there that he was there and everyone was
acting so nuts like no one knew how to
behave but one time wanna I think it was
Bill haters I heard this is like a story
that someone was just like asked him
Point Blank like what's it like to be
Tom Cruise you know like I'm not even
gonna act weird I'm just gonna straight
up ask him and he went you know
I'm just like you guys like I just have
the same problems same kind of life you
guys have same problem same dramas like
sometimes Katie will come home so yeah
he was with Katie Holm at the time Katie
will come home and she'll be like they
were out of ravioli at the ravioli store
this this kind of ravioli story time
it's not hey Tom you fucking
Scientologist there's not a fucking
ravioli story motherfucker who inspires
you when you're just like I need to
watch a YouTube video I need to like
like who do you look to
me I'm sorry
um like I have this little thing there's
this um member Carrie strugg that
gymnast in the Olympics who broke her
ankle and then she hid it again to beat
Russia and on a broken ankle she stuck
The Landing no she was gonna burn like
I'll watch it like that I'll watch like
Melanie Amaro from X Factor like her
performance I got like when I just like
need to I think I think
I don't know I think I get inspired by
just
I don't know I I I'm very much like
whenever I need to inspire myself
I just do it I can't explain is I don't
it's not a certain video or somebody
that I watch
um
I think it's maybe things that I think
any rituals
um well just more just calm down like
calm down look at the situation can you
solve it
um if you can't change it there's no
reason for you to worry if you can
change and there's no reason for your
work because you can make action in both
it's not an easy thing uh breathing
um it's hard to say when I get inspired
but that's a good question
um and I don't have an answer either
it's not something that I I go and watch
but I just think about stuff usually I
get inspired also by something pissing
me off like I now realize if something
pisses me off you have to sublimate this
into work that's my fight I love when
people don't believe in me oh that's my
life I love when people doubt me oh I
love when people think I'm not gonna rip
or I love when people think or or when
they say she ain't shit or she ain't
gonna do this or she ain't gonna be this
and then I just be like doubt me I love
it I love it I'll be like oh wait for me
on the other end partner oh and then
when you're able to go then net Nat is
the people that wanted me to fail the
most are why I succeeded like I the fact
that I have you to thank the fact that
you doubting me is why I succeeded the
reason in spite of what you thought
about me and you have to live with the
fact that you help me I'll tell people
that are shitty to me like that guy that
guy that Gary dude like people that are
mean to me that will come back around
and be like I just like to apologize for
the way I behaved I'm like no did you
help me thank you so much yeah because
you being mean to me is what helps me
say this in my book I said to all the
people that that love me to all the
people that helped me to all the people
that hurt me to all the people that have
my back you know who you are thank you
because without you I would not be
Leslie fucker Jones and at the end of
the book I said y'all know who y'all is
I love it inspire me I love when people
tell me I can't do something oh I love
it okay
thank you for the fuel I needed that
I love you I love you too thanks for
doing this I'm worried about your baby
though why because you're not gonna be a
good mother
you're doubting me good now I'm going to
be okay I'm gonna costly PS right now
that's now you're going to be great
doubt me bitch bitch you're gonna be
awful bitch
Leslie what is this coming out Leslie
fucking Jones September the 19th baby
uh yes that's actually starting the day
before September 19th in Philadelphia I
believe nice how many cities I think I'm
doing Seven Cities and then are you
gonna read from the book too yeah meet
with people and a little bit of that I'm
signing some books I'm taking some
pictures and doing some you know it's
intense and some dizzy tizzy it's a busy
busy please learn how to take a selfie
with me be ready click that's what I'm
not gonna sit in this pose I'm not gonna
know I'm not gonna do videos I'm not
doing none of that shit be ready take
your fucking picture cause I will be
like take your picture get the fuck out
of here talking to you Samsung people
I love your Leslie Jones I end these
awkwardly no red elephants love you I
end every episode with that
[Music]